[Music]
welcome back to an exciting episode of
the careful boys featuring one of our
favorite boys over here kat hey y'all
careful girl we got a careful girlfriend
it's like
yeah new age you know gender bending
concept you're a careful girl though
careful girl is she careful are you
careful i'm super careful i thought weed
was a drug like two weeks ago remember
it is a drug but it's just legalized now
speaking of boys and girls did you guys
see the island boys get booed at a club
yes
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] were they good
boys when you know the island boys the
two guys with the french fries in their
hair they're like island boys where the
island boys
racially ambiguous and a lot of tattoos
their whole thing is just saying island
boy imagine two jamaican travis barkers
except they're white yes yes with french
fries they're all tatted up right yeah
these guys yes reminds me of a little
uzi they went viral like crazy right
they even helped promote for the ufc
with dana white all that stuff they did
they they uh they showed up to this club
so that that thing they were seeing it
in the pool with their pants on it's a
free style it's supposed
but when they went to the club they sang
the exact same song and then so they're
like
boy whatever and everyone's like
[ __ ]
that's crazy
very popular why there's no beat you
know matching fits too they have the
same like red puffer jacket vest black
long sleeve
what sucks is i can't break the news to
taika because he loves them so far
you think he's gonna care if he got
booed if they got booed he won't care i
don't even know if he knows what a boo
is
i feel like he would join in and be like
wow like that's the way we celebrate
these really cool guys and uh right the
energy is contagious i feel the energy
of like boost doesn't feel good he gets
all comfortable he's like i don't like
the island boys anymore yeah that's what
he's going to say
every day
i'm an island boy he loves them he's
going to start calling island booze
like that blue
but uh yeah how
i heard that they were like cuban or
something what yeah that's what i heard
to be honest i don't give a [ __ ] about
who these guys are so i really don't
know i mean i'm interested how they even
evolved to the form we see though
they're probably so rich like how do you
get french fry hair how do you get all
these tattoos all over your body when
you look like you come from a rich
family like how do you evolve into that
one where are they from because i think
that florida or something
well that makes sense the island boys
are fraternal twins from south florida
who went viral for a song they freestyle
together in a swimming pool on tick tock
song goes wow because i'm an island boy
and i've been trying to make it oh i'm
an island boy
okay whatever the lyrics don't make
sense some of them looks like to the sun
to the top
wear a vest
like it's nothing don't even rhymes they
don't even rhyme soy tia it's my man
so i'm not even gonna say their names
because i can't read that but they've
actually got pretty normal real names
but i'm not gonna read that
the boys explain they have cuban
heritage like chandler johnson okay so
like their online names are cody acred
and flya soldier
and then real name is frankie and alex
damn how underwhelming
that's so underwhelming shout outs right
to frankie and ellen frank and alex
what's what's their last name do they
have that in there or no no no i island
boys don't have last names they uh
their songs catchy though i saw another
tick tock where like an actual musician
musician that plays like drums saxophone
all that stuff he made a beat to what
they were seeing and it came out pretty
sick
bart just wants us to like the island
boys hey you know what i hate here
so i don't know anything about these
people is this like a tick tock
to the words all right here let me
listen to how some words don't rhyme but
they try to like change ball and rhyming
with top or something
the dude on the right has way better
bars though they're fascinating that's
better bars better flow wait that dude i
saw that picture where the guy has so
much cash in his hand
like i can't believe they're killing it
with that he looks like this will hold
cash in his hand every day michael
but i know that's not real though that
could be real for all i know i know man
you never know with these guys out there
you know these island boys he looks like
that rugrats doll dude yeah they look
also
yeah they look like cynthia dude that's
right
it was a pretty chill song though i
don't know
it's moments like this when you go i'm a
[ __ ] boomer bro
what the [ __ ] is this no i go i had a
missed opportunity
for halloween us three could have been
island
[Laughter]
it was get fake tats all over our bodies
i would have known that i would have
just thought it was like six nine or
something yeah true but maybe that's
just like in right that's like kind of
just the the fashion the style that's
the way it is
just like a collage of tattoos that just
don't make sense probably yeah just a
bunch a lot of like really really uh
distinct and very edgy features whether
it be like grills to like missing teeth
or tattoos like in your nails so like
you know
head i want crazy
fry hair yeah like really like people
are actually uh surgically getting
diamonds or jewelry and stuff like
implanted in them so they have like
third eyes and random [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah i'm gonna do french fry hair
somehow
i think it's expressive i think that's
cool hey why it gets like super famous i
think it's a debate whether or not
people are like kind of the laughing
with you or laughing at you they're
laughing at these dudes for sure you
know what i'm saying but i want to see
him put on a t-shirt without messing up
his hair
i know how does he put a shirt on i
don't wear shirts don't wear shirts you
never wear their hair like that every
morning or it just stays like that oh
yeah how do they sleep that must be so
much upkeep i wish my anime was here
because that fall used to literally have
the most
perfectly done like that ryan may he was
an anime character his hair his [ __ ]
seriously looked like cloud stripe from
final fantasy yeah every day and he
would all and it wasn't just like uh
he didn't ever come off as one of those
pompous guys who probably took like 17
hours doing it because he would be
willing to do like head spins like jump
on his [ __ ] head and stuff and then
get up like yeah
it's still perfect how the hell does
that happen i don't [ __ ] know it's
[ __ ] how's he so perfect i just love
some people more why are you so perfect
ryan's so perfect he's so [ __ ]
perfect he does have perfect hair maybe
it's karma because his penis had to get
so much surgery so then afterwards god's
like
all right you live through [ __ ] homie
what happened to her yeah what's the
story with the penis you guys got to
watch that jk news episode
we just started talking about his story
in this episode without him he got
circumcision at a later date later age
12 12. oh yeah that's pretty old and
then when the doctor was jacking him off
he realized he had a tumor in his ball
side so he had to get another surgery
through his appendix or whatever the
[ __ ] daddy
did i heard that like going through his
nipple or something had to go through
his [ __ ] throat yeah
and then pull the ball
because you can't cut the sex you gotta
like go through the [ __ ] ear
all the way down you're pulling like
yeah yeah
yeah and then pull the ball out do
surgery push the ball back oh they
didn't take it out holy [ __ ] but yeah
this
wow
plus or minus yeah who knows yeah and
you got it at 12 when you have like
random boners all the time so every time
i had a phone there's just blood
but that's the summary so you got to
watch the whole jk news episode all
right all right are you circumcised i am
not a circumcised actor are you
circumcised uh no not currently i might
do it later in life really
thinking about it you know but not in
together but at the same time yeah at
the same time yeah just just me you know
different like you guys are circumcised
yeah yeah why did you guys deny being
asian yeah what do you mean deny being
most asian guys are
most asian parents don't get their kids
i've wanted to be white my whole life
are you catholic huh are you catholic i
just want to fit in oh okay god
no my parents are buddhists okay why do
you think why do you think some asian
parents make the decision to do it when
they don't do it back in asia
you know what i mean maybe they couldn't
afford it is your dad circumcised
uh i haven't seen his dick and
you never asked a real long time i think
he is though yeah i think he is i want
to say he is i thought they don't do it
in vietnam
i don't know i actually don't know if my
dad's circumstance you should ask him
every time i saw his dick he had a boner
call him
[Laughter]
wait is it were you a fine ass baby no
it was because like every time i saw him
peek i remember seeing his dick when i
was a kid i'm like whoa that's huge and
now that he was probably just big like a
bigger person so you just thought he had
a boner because he had warning wood now
i realized because i was a kid and i was
like man that thing is big and stiff
well you're just sitting in the bathroom
in the morning just waiting for the
morning wood to come through you know
when you're like three feet tall that's
just your view everywhere
so you're like i could be playing in the
laundry basket the eye level will do my
best
yeah and then there's a [ __ ] your
dad's just peeing somewhere always
he probably walks into the bathroom and
i just go whoa he's peeing from a
different height than me and i look i'm
like was he doing the boner thing where
he has to like bend down like this
i don't remember i don't remember those
details i just remember you bend down
from the torso versus just like pushing
it down a little sometimes sometimes
yeah yeah sometimes it depends it
depends on the day you know unless you
pee on the back of the toilet that's why
you gotta like exhale so that you're not
like fighting the like pressure yeah you
gotta you gotta center your chi first
before you pee with a boner
i have i have the the lady of the room a
question so like have you had both
uncircumcised and circumcised dicks uh
no i have only slept with like
four people in my life and they're all
circumcised they were all circumcised
today's video is brought to you by
upstart it's almost a new year so it's
time to start thinking about your
resolutions how about adding financial
freedom to the list with a little bit of
help from upstar upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether you're
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart uses your credit and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 up to 50 000
wow
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record and don't forget to use
this specific url so they know that we
sent you go get it baby loan amounts
will be determined by your credit income
and other information that you provide
on the loan application go to
upstart.com off the record and get your
financial freedom today damn it because
i want to ask does it feel different i
always wanted to just because i feel
like that's unexplored territory i heard
it feels better for the guy i don't know
about girls oh
well i wouldn't know because i i can't
compare
yeah that's why it's better for the guy
because there are more nerves on your
foreskin getting rid of the foreskin
kills awful lot of nerves so you still
have more you have more sensitivity if
you still have but i heard that
uncircumcised guys come too fast yeah
see
i still have that problem
i've done research on online and of
course you have my course yes wait are
you uncircumcised i am i'm circumcised
but sometimes i just go on like random
research tangents and i'm like well what
is it like to have sex with an
uncircumcised you know for women or for
guys you're into what they say what they
say and one of the things that people
say is that um it's like way less smelly
when it's circumcised it's obviously
smelly there's like way less uh you know
skin for steps to hide in eugenic issue
you should be clean
yeah you gotta clean out your meg i
shower before i [ __ ] yeah but sometimes
you don't have time though
oh yeah
michael's at the forest bro he's always
in a rush to [ __ ] this guy that wasn't a
rush in life michael said time is money
and i gotta [ __ ] now i don't know mike
was a player like i don't have time for
a shower let's go into that
amp and bathroom baby yeah mike's like
we only got two hours i can't be wasting
time on showering
he's on a road trip and [ __ ] he goes
wide up all over honey
like do you schedule your love making
sessions no but maybe i should because
we're pretty busy and don't have time
and i feel like it's like
tiredness wins out a lot of the time
it's like
you know like you schedule yours right
honestly bart puts it in his schedule
it's tough but it's tough with the kids
though you said that you send geo google
invite requests
no you know what helped out a lot though
school yeah
oh yeah tell that [ __ ] to go to school
school right because like i think i
think everyone also has their horniest
period you know throughout the day some
people are morning [ __ ] and night
[ __ ] both me and g are actually the
horniest mid-day tight and then that's
like the most unproductive time i know
so what you're saying about like in an
hour and a half you're gonna like
randomly be like really hot you're just
gonna be like this on the side
[Laughter]
i'm always walking my hips forward my
shirt off yeah i gotta leave with your
dick man he has to get a brisk walk or
he's gonna try to [ __ ] one of us no but
school helped out because then now at
night we're still gonna get just as
tired because of the kid but then at
least midday
um there's open time you know we're not
under superb time
under child supervision you don't have
to schedule your [ __ ] anymore
we'll schedule it sometimes too like and
it doesn't work out cause you're so
[ __ ] tired
scheduled time be usually if you had to
schedule one good question 30 in the
morning when he wakes up right before
[ __ ] i had to schedule like in
between the workout as a workout super
set as a pre-workout right there
probably right after a workout is the
best
really
shower after that because you're all
pumped up huh cause he's all looking at
himself like i feel good now no because
you know your endorphins are going like
you just like hit some heavy squats or
whatever like your test is high it just
feels good but what if you got to be
productive that day and then you bust
nuts and you're just like i'mma go to
sleep
this sounds like a personal experience
yeah i can't
dude if i [ __ ] do it in the morning
man i'm like
oh no i'll go back to sleep missiles
come narcolepsy yeah what's your optimal
time joe
for lovemaking nighttime i'm a nighttime
lover i feel like i'm like a afternoon
time you know not too
early no afternoon tea kind of guy i am
but like i also have done it before work
as well and i do realize that um
sometimes i just feel really horny
before i have to do a lot of stuff
just like procrastinating or something
but uh that's like some college [ __ ]
dude you're like oh i gotta study oh i
got too much anxiety i gotta get this
out of my system and you [ __ ] watch
some porn you beat off and then you just
go to [ __ ] sleep and yes you get no
[ __ ] words
i'm all the way with you all the way
until go to sleep
i remember how to like big examine in
your life okay before i study i gotta
jack off to get out the [ __ ] wiggles
yeah and then you [ __ ] jack off and
you just pass out and you're like [ __ ] i
missed like four hours of studying you
got to get out the wiggles yo yeah i get
the wiggles out but i don't think i like
passed out i think i was really
efficient with my uh wigglage yeah yeah
you don't wiggle too hard that you're
gonna no i'm not i'm not doing like 90
minutes of porn in order to get my
wiggles out you know what i mean i'm
like i'm like i got the anxiety i'm
gonna get it out i'm gonna [ __ ] beat
off to something that i know it's a
go-to the only true way to get the
wiggles out you gotta edge at least five
times
at least five yeah and then by the time
you bust on the sixth time you're like
oh
yeah then you immediately fall asleep
yeah with your pants around your ankles
i do have to agree with you there
because if you edge five times like the
squirt's like way more intense
it's the bellagio show as a lady before
you do stuff do you ever feel like you
got to get a nut off before you do a
bunch of like chores or errands or like
i'm not aaron i do feel like i have to
get enough off in order to sleep a lot
of the time so if i i feel like i am
staying up later than i should i'll keep
jacking off yeah uh until i fall asleep
and sometimes that'll be like round
after round after round i just like i
need to sleep yeah yeah you got to get
out your system wow so you do it almost
every night then uh only when i can't
sleep i'm so tired
yes absolutely and my girls get
energized from orgasm sometimes but i
feel like i also know my body well
enough to know like how to make myself
want to go to sleep after all these guys
are like cat uh you want some more
coffee i heard uh you you're
trying to get her to [ __ ] sleep not
sleep and [ __ ]
after they hear this
i remember telling my boyfriend that
once and he like gets so weirded out by
the thought of me jacking off
which is like so weird he used to like
work important he's like like an actual
sex worker but he's so like i think i've
domesticated him so much because now
he's like going to cut down christmas
trees and [ __ ] like he only wants to
like have sexy time on like a sunday
after he showers after his workout he's
like super like docile now and i'm just
looking at him like this is not what i
signed up for you're like i wanted a
[ __ ] porn star what the [ __ ] bro
and now i have like a it's like one of
those girls who will adopt a pit bull
who's like on the verge of getting
euphemic euphemized and then she brings
them home and suddenly he's in like a
sweater like only eats like organic
dog food like that's what i did with my
boyfriend yeah that's your fault then
yeah it is because you you turned you
you really turned a hoe into a housewife
i know
are you the first one ever yeah i think
so people told me it couldn't be done
yeah so you did it this would happen i
did it see vietnamese girls dudes
vietnamese girls man they got to
exchange you that's true rick they
always say like
girls want to fix dudes and they're like
that's impossible bro what are you doing
but then they all want to be cat that's
what it is what's the secret to your
success um i think the secret to my
success is
one
i think i got a good one because he's
one of those guys with like um
like attachment issues because he didn't
really have a family growing up so he's
like craves attention it's really like
damaged goods you have a hostage
issue is number one cell phone to piece
back together because he's like he was
one of those guys who like he went after
me and i wanted nothing to do with him
and then when i did i think i had shown
him a lot of love and affection he
hasn't had in a long time and so every
time we fought and i would tell him like
oh i don't want to like be with you
anymore he would then crumble as a
thought of like oh i'm not going to have
this love and affection any longer like
i think i like
basically gave him stockholm syndrome
it's like a lot of
verbal and then
love bombing i think that's how i got
him but he's like into it so it's not
like a bad toxic thing he loves it you
probably do do you guys roll role play
like him being an american prisoner of
war in vietnam i wish i wish i wish he
would do [ __ ] like that he will not do
[ __ ] like that anymore i talked about
how he doesn't want to have a threesome
like he literally doesn't want to do
anything fun like nothing do the rambo
scene where you have leeches on your
nipples and your vagina and then you
have to cut the leeches off
absolutely oh my god i would have a
[ __ ] fuel day with that but meanwhile
he's like no that's too much
he has to be like in a bamboo jail cell
and then you're just like a soldier like
guarding him and he has to [ __ ]
seduce you so he could get out of prison
we gotta build a bamboo jail i also
wanna do that tropic thunder scene with
the like really young drug lord uh
beating simple jack
and then he could be simply civil jack
do we know that john chung
he's not a young guy anymore he's that
young anymore buddy brandon
[Laughter]
that's crazy
yeah we shot danger boys with them
you